ok je m'appelle à manama
[Musique]
king j'ai dit parkings voies keen'v
j'adore les 12 groupes et des cours que
lors du prime time bientôt que batman aa
mais comme j'étais beach au nord de
rabat blanc s'en va cela fait bientôt là
pas de kingson la région tout noir
durable eu comme la trace de ton père si
les impôts l'argent n'est vraiment pas
terrible
martin
bonne nouvelle
si la pac ont perdu
qui fait a déjà fait cet album qui me
plaît ce qui fait vibrer les filets
[Musique]
hier quatre ans comme moi la raison
qu'une fois ma tétouan qu'une nuit je
t'en prie rien qu'une fois mains des
toits ou peut-être vaut la vie si j'ai
de la chance
le mv [ __ ] tu n'auras pas de
deuxième vie et mon but ici mettez pas
de deux verres shift est pas marrant
mais tu arrêtes de me faire rire et on
t'écoute que dans les combines mais qu
on dirait un bourgeois qui veut faire le
type sa masse pour rigoler j'ai regardé
l'interview me fait évidement du ragga
depuis 2005 tard chanter la violence
pire que la haine jeudi noir est à sa
seconde comme les pumas par lés frites
bien que tu es reste flou qui brille
compter sur scène et 5 secondes pour
passer donc mâcon tout ce que j'ai à
dire
du parti
l'allemagne en a pas un qui me plaît je
comprends qu'ils veuillent près
similaire
aucune mai
[Musique]
tavin complet jeudi pouvait enfoncer
cette année à 16 ans à l'époque qui veut
ça canada mais george et moi flo touarga
centime n'est pas pris la mauvaise la
chaque nouveau sont des sceaux y
travaille on les entasse est ce que
j'aime et toi
quand personne mais des sources
je te laisse pousser la barbe nous
ce épousé le dalo fait décent où tu
charme et tu es marié depuis 12 ans
c'est bon si c'est trop jean veil
t'as pas compris
m
bonduelle
tu ne l'as pas compris ce qu'on dit
pauline b on sent bien que c'est pas ta
mère
jean bayle à l'époque qui n'est acquis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]